regular chess okay well I'm gonna try
this well I'll do this again they're
gonna go for it get the Queen's off
already happened earlier against oh it
was his name Derek Derek I play this
against and night here and then f6 so
let's do this box that night out home
for the king and now before this Bishop
gets on this diagonal I think I do well
to be on the diagonal weak point follow
up bishop e6 97 King f6 or not let me
let me guard this so similar if you were
here earlier in the stream this was
already played and I touched down how
this night could turn out to be out of
play in the that earlier game it did
turn out to be out of play so actually
let me do this first because I guess
white was looking at expanding with be
four and what else well if I play here
well I better play here I guess I guess
there's a pond push attack it again and
then the bishop could actually defend so
well that's not being played and instead
this this is being played isn't it let's
try this
I should have bought more about that
move why did I go to e7 why did I go to
e7 I shouldn't have done that let me
maybe get rid of this night or no no I'm
not necessarily going to get rid of the
night maybe I could come around in this
direction my main thing here is that if
Bishop takes pawn I have Bishop takes on
f2 ok let's play here and what else
okay wait Castle I still have that check
available I think this is right though
just so that c5 isn't played okay let me
make sure that that night is taken and
I'll look to maybe play a 4 and clamp
down on that a and B pond right there
okay that's not happening though is it
let's take here I get the a file there
for my pieces and I could take the night
I'd like to be able to take the night in
the play here I only issue though is
that what if after i take care pond
takes bishop
maybe I could do something else I'm
going to try this and my idea with this
is that if Bishop here then I'll take
the night and if pawn takes Bishop then
I'm getting up minor piece so I want to
maybe chase this Bishop to this square
if pond takes I recapture here and I'm
threatening Bishop takes Knight and then
grab the bishop and I'd like to soon get
my night like right here it's going to
take forever a night trying to get two
squares diagonally that's tough to get
in so let me do this and then follow up
with bishop to d4 now it is available
ok yeah so Bishop to d4 and well one
next
ok
I like my position I like this Bishop I
like having this rook activity the rook
can't be challenged this Bishop is doing
a lot of stuff of course if I play here
it could get rid of it but I'm okay with
that actually I'm seeing that I could
target maybe f2 opposite color bishops
if you enter that sort of situation
you'll be sure or excuse me be sure to
know whether or not your bishop can have
a constructive role and I believe it
could so now what Brooke a2 I could hit
this guy I could just get my other book
on this file and what else night F 796
is a possibility I like that because I'd
be hitting both of these guys I'm in a
spot to meet b5 with c5 so let's
actually save my night I think you could
turn out to be a pain I could do this as
well but ok let's just close this up
I've control over this there's nothing
happening here my bishop is well
positioned doubling the rooks on the a
and then night to d6 ok this is
difficult to defend now in fact it's
undefendable
what else
okay I'm just winning this pond
this rook is doing a real lot so once
I'm once your understanding is at the
point in the chess game where you know
to just get your minor pieces out and
get castled and your rooks in particular
on open files that next step you're
going to be looking forward to is
getting your rooks functioning along
ranks moving it once it's on an open
file or half of a file look for a pivot
point along that file and right now it's
it's contributing them in both
directions to functions I could give a
fork here get this guy just looking for
the cleanest win Oh actually just this
this is a fork coming up but it doesn't
really work miscalculation there if I
play night here there's just rook here
okay let's uh let me do this instead I
want to get that bishop and then those
rooks are going to be finding it
difficult to get active because I
control both open files so as a
follow-up so I do this just so I don't
have to worry about pawn push and then a
rook eventually attacking my pond like
that just going to do that to be extra
cautious and let me put pressure on this
guy and then I guess play here I guess
one of those is going to get active real
soon maybe I could sneak by King up in
this direction let me do this first
paving away for a king entry in this
direction oh actually I could get this
pond no time issue okay King and King
position as soon as the rook leaves i'm
going to put immediate pressure on this
pond I guess this pond could fall bone
bone bone
but uh there's no time it's the biggest
thing good game um let me back up
and what else okay let's see again I
don't know how how much really you could
get with playing the white pieces if
you're going to go forward with the
Queen exchange that early on yes again
I'm castled but you really can't take
advantage of that I did reference
earlier that you could look into f4 and
maybe Knight f3 because otherwise we
have this after Knight f3 f6 and the
night is kind of dead to the game and
let me just kind of skim through here
what did this night do the whole game he
didn't do anything he came there very
early on Knight f3 was played on move 7
and he ended up just getting captured
how many moves later it was a long long
way off but I'm he just wasn't able to
do anything so that's again some some
way you can maybe be getting that a
knight a bit more active by going
forward with them
oh right here right here consider c5
right here and what else c5 followed by
Bishop to e3 and I think I'm in some
trouble so this this night move was
pretty good I think just following up
with clamping down on this pond and then
following up with pond here and I'm in
some hot water I have to always be on
the lookout for let's say night to be 6
stuff or here's another thing your night
that was on f3 could be doing stuff in
the following way Knight d2 to c4 to be
six starts off with c5 support point on
b6 follow up Bishop e3 night d 2 nite c
4 and then your pick either one of these
squares seems pretty appealing so that's
a I'm almost certain a computer would be
saying something like c5 right here it
just seems really really really good so
look into that